yeah i've been moving and it's it's it's
almost done okay it's it's almost time
it's almost done it's never almost done
you think it's done right okay i think
it's done and then there's something
else that pops up all right
how do you how did you guys decide how
you want to decorate your rooms
uh
okay you know the hottest i'm gonna
sound like a [ __ ] robot right now but
i'm just like i look at a blank canvas
right i don't know i i know i'm meant to
show my personality and i'm just like
what do i show how do i show personality
give me a blank space i have no idea
what he's what i
all right i've got all these jojo
posters that's a must that's going
somewhere on the wall i've got these big
ass walls all right so then i know
that's going there so then
i kind of have to figure out what goes
in between the posters
around yeah and then it kind of starts
to kind of form yeah and then i'm like
okay here's what i want i want
soundproofing i want uh i want carpet i
want soundproof squares so i have an
idea of stuff i want yeah and then it's
kind of putting it together and then
thinking okay how would it look like
that if you know my old room it was like
i want this thing on the wall that's it
i want posters of this there's that and
yeah so for me the problem is is that my
room and the rest of my house is
designed by two different people
my room is yeah but your room still
looks good yeah my room is good but like
the way we the way myself and aki think
about interior design is completely like
on the opposite side question would you
decorate your bedroom if if you lived
alone
yeah really what would you decorate it
with no i don't know i i i've never
decorated my life which is which is why
it's so [ __ ] difficult for me right
because the way i approach into you
where are you going to decorate your
bedroom well yeah no oh no my office
sorry all right so yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i mean it's the same kind of deal
where my approach to interior design is
my same approach i have with like
engineering it's all about practicality
and that's just not good for interior
design
i'm just like i i know because here's
here's my biggest problem with
trying to fill up my room right now in
my office is i know what looks bad
but i don't know how to make it look
good
okay see because like if you were if you
if you're an engineer when it comes to
interior design i'm like a programmer
where it's like
if white wall equals true fill white
wall with something it's like that's it
it's like it's like there's no like
there's no like opinion of like oh maybe
i should put something he's like no if
there's a space on my wall i'm gonna
find something to fill it up
yeah i one thing that's good about
living in japan is that japan is
extremely focused on practicality yeah
of like everything in your house yeah
everything has to be practical yeah so i
kind of took a lot of that in mind when
i made my office i i'm gonna make an
office tour video at some point in my
main channel where i just go through
everything that i did in the office
because i think it's really i think i
did i'm really happy with my office it
took me goddamn forever though it's also
easy views it's only yeah yeah but also
i want to talk about it because it took
me goddamn forever so i want to get some
value out of it two [ __ ] weeks just
to soundproof the [ __ ] room
but
i think it's really easy to decorate a
room in japan when you can think more on
like practical sides of things like
you're like okay i want this here like i
want all my anime figures yeah but i
don't want i don't want them in just
like a cabinet like a glasswarm because
i want to be able to move it so i can
access the cupboards behind it but i
don't want it on the wall with all the
posters it'll block them so it's kind of
like all right so there's like 10 000
things you got to consider but you're
just trying to like compute them all but
then at some point you just got to do
something and then see how it looks
because i hope you didn't waste it yeah
because because that's that's like as as
i've just established i hate wasting
time and i'm just like i just want
something that looks good i just don't
know how to make it look good without
just trying it out what if what if what
if i like rearrange all my furniture
after i've just spent all this time
building it and like you know it's doing
my tests
and then it just looks [ __ ] what if it
just looks [ __ ] because like i'm i have
a bunch of like anime merch yeah and
like i just i just don't know how to
make it look good like i've tried
putting my anime figures on like a shelf
or something and i don't know why i just
don't think
having a bunch of anime figures on the
shelf looks good for my for my aesthetic
i say this i said it was with all this
[ __ ] but i think it works for
aesthetically yeah and i it
i don't know if we came to this by luck
or if it just you know okay so so the
way that archie does which i think is
kind of genius is that what she does is
when we first moved in right i was like
i'm gonna do my room you do the rest of
the house because you clearly have a
better sense of it than i do so what she
does is she took photos of the empty
room right and then she would go into
photoshop and literally just photoshop
in different things that she was
thinking about to like move it around
and if it looks good then she buys it
yeah and puts it exactly where she
envisioned it to be yeah and and because
then you know yeah what it looks like
before you bought it like it's kind of a
big brain buy what you need measure it
yeah because it measures well one one
thing i've like noticed around anime
merch now now that i'm like trying to
make my room actually look cool so a lot
of anime merch just looks really tacky
yeah
and i didn't like i didn't realize this
until now that i've moved to japan and
we've got like some cooler things but
like i was like maybe i'll try putting
some wool scrolls up and now i'm like
even though even wool scrolls just look
like i like yes i've graduated from wall
scrolls yes hello i have been to an
anime convention that is that is the
look when you put up wall scrolls now
i've never understood the appeal of wall
scrolls i'll be honest with you i i
they look [ __ ]
i mean i did they like they're like you
know like posters you can get them
framed yeah they look so clean so so
like symmetrical as well so beautiful
yeah and then the nice glass panel or
plastic whatever the [ __ ] it is yeah and
then you got this like poorly printed
piece of paper with two plastic scrolls
the top and the bottom and it's never
like [ __ ] you know the string just
looks so tacky the string looks right
we're just calling out everyone
and i'm like i liked it at the time but
then when i learned about like framed
stuff yeah that's when i was like oh but
here's the thing right like those jojo
posters that i have yeah they're
thirteen dollars in a poster obviously
it's in japan right yeah yeah yeah and
then the frame is like 12 bucks yeah
that's like 25 bucks for a clean ass
massive like really high quality that's
cheaper than a lot of
schools
like sometimes 30 bucks yeah we're
talking like even the a4 ones like 20
bucks
and they're always like they always
don't look as good like the print is
never as clean like i i don't know man i
just i don't see a wall yeah i'm i'm
past the wall scroll phase as well which
is why i like i i had wall scrolls in my
old office and i'm just like this just
looks tacky but i don't know how to uh i
don't know what i want to replace it
with
and now now now i'm going through that
problem where i have to figure out what
i want to replace it with what i have
like
it's it's so it's just live in japan
it's so energy that you can get these
because like my four prints i think i've
done like one cool thing with my office
right because i have like i have like a
few cool anime merch and i'm just like
what if i just put this all in a glass
case and i so i bought like a uh like a
glass case which is like a four
four component glass case
and i you know i filled up like the top
one was the gingivito bag that's uh that
i got um the second one was like all the
anime watches that i've got as well
third case was all the wine
um or the wine equipment or the anime
wine equipment that me and sydney have
collected and the fourth case is going
to be for
the slam dunk air jordans that i found
on yahoo auction oh yeah and i i put it
up and i'm just like damn this looks
awesome yeah and then i realized that's
like one 100th of the entire [ __ ]
room [ __ ]
that means you gotta start collecting
more stuff and i'm just like oh it looks
cool but like it's like compare like
putting it next to everything else it
just looks so empty now that one tenth
of my room looks
right
people when they rob your house man
they're going right for that camera
the entire
manitoba wealth is stored in that one
glass four cabin like you've been
collecting jojo figures or jojo [ __ ]
merch i'm just like this is this is like
this is how my collection starts yeah it
starts with one cabinet yeah oh my gosh
yeah
no i i i bought one of those um i didn't
buy a glass cabinet because i want to be
able to move it because it's blocking my
cupboards so i bought one on wheels that
i can just kind of like shove out the
way oh yeah well one thing i definitely
underestimated was how heavy glass is oh
yeah yeah extremely so yeah
why
why what made you
know what i mean like oh that looks
light i i felt like there was another
point coming like
you literally just went glass is heavy
yeah
i was like okay why why did you learn
this what made you realize okay because
we're like glass-heavy
my point was that glass was heavy and i
did not like i did not
think it was heavy i didn't like [ __ ]
glass i didn't think about this okay i
don't think about this [ __ ]
wait i think everyone knows glasses
because water is wet
i i get because like one big issue i've
had with living in the house now is that
you have to carry things upstairs
and luckily enough my office is on the
ground floor because i had the choice
between mine being on the ground floor
and mine being on the top floor and i'm
just like i want a glass case
obviously yeah and i'm just like once i
got the glass case delivered
i was just like was glass always as
heavy
because
i don't know how i was meant to carry
this upstairs if i needed to but thank
god i did it glass in japan is really
[ __ ] heavy
yeah
so that was my story god discovered
[ __ ]